Virginia Governor Ralph North is now
denying that he appeared in a blackface
Ku Klux Klan photo on his medical school
yearbook page one day after apologizing
for appearing in a blackface Ku Klux
Klan photo on his medical school
yearbook page he also denies ever
appearing in blackface except for that
time he wore blackface to a Michael
Jackson impersonator contest but don't
worry he won't perform the moonwalk
anymore because that would be
inappropriate according to his wife oh
yeah also he supports killing babies
after they've been born we will analyze
the sheer political brilliance with
which Democrats took down one of their
own governors to avoid talking about
their growing support for infanticide
then variations on a theme an Indian man
sues his parents for giving birth to him
without his consent the nerve of them
all life is suffering he says but a new
study shows that people who have endured
the most suffering may live the longest
lives we will try to make sense of the
competing cultures of life and death
finally speaking of death Superbowl 53
and the death of football
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Ralph Northam what a tragedy in three
acts a comedy and a tragedy in three
acts we'll get to it in a second but
first let me talk to you about you know
how much I love this purple mattress
I am a proselytizer for purple mattress
it has saved my marriage it certainly
saved my back it is the greatest
mattress I have ever slept on I have
recommended it to all of my friends you
need to get it yourself I'm telling you
it is the best sleep that you will ever
get it is unlike any bed you've ever
slept on it's not quite a memory foam
it's not an innerspring it's this new
technology developed by rocket
scientists somehow it is both firm and
soft at the same time that doesn't sound
like it makes sense it does though it
sleeps very cool it just feels great I
got mine in California King as someone
who sleeps 19 to 25 hours a day I highly
recommend it you've got to make sure
that you've got a good quality bed it
will change your life
purple matte it's going to feel
different than anything you've ever
tried it is unique you can 108 risk free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund you won't want to backed by a
10-year warranty free shipping and
returns free in-home set up an old
mattress removal you were gonna love
purple right now my listeners get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts are offering site-wide how do
you do it pull over your car right now
take out your phone text qoph FAC o VF
EF e two four seven four seven four
seven the only way to get this free
pillow is to text cough FA Co V Fe Fe
two four seven four seven four seven Co
V Fe Fe for seven boards and four seven
message and data rates apply okay now
look I love purple mattress but now we
can get to one of the most incredible
political displays of of the last three
or four years other than everything
Donald Trump's done the the Ralph
Northam turnaround is a jaw-dropping
political display for those of you who
missed it over the weekend here is
Democrat Virginia Governor Ralph Northam
reacting to the news that on his medical
school yearbook page is a photo of a man
in blackface and a man wearing a Ku Klux
Klan outfit this according to the
Washington Post Ralph Northam
is in this photo Ralph Northam this gets
exposed and he comes out and apologizes
that photo and the racist and offensive
attitudes that represents does not
reflect that person I am today or the
way that I have conducted myself as a
soldier a doctor and a public servant I
am deeply sorry I cannot change the
decisions I made nor can I undo the harm
my behavior calls then and today but I
accept responsibility for my past
actions and I am ready to do the hard
work of regaining your trust he accepts
responsibility he is apologizing he's
about to work to gain back your trust
and then he realized wait a minute I'm a
Democrat I don't need to apologize for
anything
I don't need to take responsibility
yippee I'm a Democrat governor so then a
day later he goes out and uh apologizes
and I am not and will not
it was offensive racist and when my
staff showed me the photo in question
yesterday I was seeing it for the first
time I did not purchase the EDM s period
and I was unaware of what my tastes when
I was confronted with the images
yesterday I was a poll that they
appeared on my page but I believed them
and now that I am NOT either of the
people in that photo I stand by my
statement of apology to the many
Virginians who were hurt by seeing this
content on a yearbook page that belongs
to me being a leftist means never having
to say you're sorry listen to that
language then he says well I'm
apologizing that there was a racially
offensive photo on my yearbook page then
he asks us to believe that he never saw
the yearbook never purchased the
yearbook had nothing to do with the
photo being on his page although then
one wonders why was it on the page and
why are you sorry that it appeared on
the page then he says listen to the
language I believe that I was not either
of the people on that page now if that
photo comes that guy in blackface
guy wearing a Ku Klux Klan uniform
especially if you're a Democrat governor
I mean that you know that's there's a
long history of Democrat governor's
wearing that uniform if that appears and
you weren't in that photo wouldn't you
come and say it's not me you wouldn't
apologize for it when you then
unapologetic it's not me I'm not in that
photo I didn't do that
so come on get off it this is a
political dirty trick or something like
that instead he's just saying don't
believe your lying eyes this is what
they always do this reminds me of joy
read joy read is that MSNBC commentator
and it came out that she had written on
her blog all of these anti-gay writings
years ago and all of these anti-gay
writings come out and she denies that
they were there she says I don't know
how they got there maybe it got hacked
maybe my old webs
I ex post facto got hacked and then all
of these anti-gay writings appeared
there and well anyway I mean no
responsibility it's not me and then so
he doesn't deny that he wore black face
ever
his excuse Ralph Northam is that he's he
wasn't wearing black face in this photo
but he has worn black face before he
wore black face for a Michael Jackson
impersonation contest that's up to them
you know everything is in sound bytes
these days but I really do believe that
both of them are wrong but there's a
contrast but seen between the black face
and someone standing there in a Klu Klux
Klan outfit and me dressed up in a
Michael Jackson costume for a dance
contest and and again they're both wrong
but I would hope people would see the
contrast so speaking of seeing contrasts
I the one reason this Michael Jackson
line is just obviously bogus is that
Ralph Northam today is much darker
skinned than Michael Jackson for much of
his career so that you know the timeline
is very important here on when you're
doing your Michael Jackson impersonation
but why is he admitting that he wore
blackface for a Michael Jackson contest
or party or whatever the reason he's
doing it is that the guy's obviously
worn blackface he almost certainly wore
blackface on that photo he wear
blackface already wore the hood I don't
know which one's better for Ralph
Northam but he knows he's done it and he
knows that probably some other photos
exist if this guy was going out wearing
blackface in the 80s probably that's not
the only photograph if one of the
photographs makes it to his medical
school yearbook page probably they're
gonna come out and so when the next
photo comes out it's going to be much
more difficult for Northam to have any
credibility not that he has any now but
the best part of the Michael Jackson
line is the PS still a resistance of
this whole beautiful press conference
when a reporter asks him to do the
moonwalk and he almost doesn't
people that do that kind of research
perhaps they should have looked at that
yes that's right
[Music]
my wife says in appropriate
circumstances are you still able to
dance the moonwalk and what is it for
those of you who couldn't see it he
looks around he's looking around for a
place on the stage to do the moonwalk
and he's smiling and I probably doesn't
know how to do the moonwalk I wish if
only his wife weren't there we could
have seen that somehow the press
conference would have been even better
really beautiful so now after this press
conference
all of a sudden leading Democrats are
coming out against the guy Terry
McAuliffe ex governor of Virginia Eric
Holder ex Attorney General Hillary
Clinton former future President of the
United States they're all coming after
saying he'd no law he doesn't have the
judgment he can't be Prevnar of Virginia
he's got to resign he's got to get out
of office you'll notice all of these
Democrats were waiting until after the
press conference it wasn't right when
the photo came out it wasn't you know
any of his other actions this governor
it was after this press conference they
realized this guy is not capable of
remaining in office he's looking too bad
for us what this is about
the reason that that Ralph Northam is
being pushed out of office is not
because he wore black face or a ku ku ku
Klux Klan hood 35 years ago he's being
pushed out for being an incompetent
spokesman for the Democrat Party and
what this is really about is not about
blackface or racism or bigotry what this
is all really about is abortion and this
was an amazing move by the Democrat
Party I don't know who was behind this I
don't know exactly where the tip-off
came from I don't know how it all played
out moment to moment but pivoting this
conversation from this man endorsing
infanticide to this man having worn
blackface 35 years ago so he's got to go
this was one of the most brilliant
strategic communication strategies I
have crisis management strategies that I
have ever seen it totally worked we will
explain how it worked what it means what
it means for the culture of death but
first let's let's talk about something
beautiful like 1-800 flowers right now
gentlemen especially most of us have
started racking our brains what are we
going to get for Valentine's Day to make
her gift special with 1-800 flowers calm
it's really not that complicated
Rosen's from 1-800 flowers are a
no-brainer right now when you order
early 1-800 flowers has amazing deals on
vibrant and romantic Valentine's rose
bouquets arrangements and more starting
at just $29.99 listen I've used a lot of
different flower services some of them
are really not great 1-800 flowers calm
will get you beautiful bouquets at great
prices they are they're just tremendous
so many unbelievable deals from 1-800
flowers you have to hurry I check it out
the the beauty the quality of them it's
so easy to order I really love it and
you know fortunately obviously sweet
little ELISA would never listen to my
show so I can just tell you I'm
obviously using this for Valentine's Day
you should do treat your lady as though
she is the finest wife in the world
sweet little ELISA use 1-800 flowers
picked at their peak they're shipped
overnight to ensure freshness and her
amazement a bouquet prices will be going
up soon so take advantage today pick
your delivery date 1-800 flowers we'll
handle the rest go to the Rose Authority
1-800 flowers calm to order valentines
bouquets arrangements and more starting
at $29.99 100 flowers calm click the
radio icon enter promo code cough FAC OV
e fe fe order today and save it 1-800
flowers calm promo code cough fa co v fe
f e co VF e fe another and that's
another aphrodisiac for Valentine's Day
check it out you're gonna love it
this was the brilliance of this Ralph
Northam Democrat strategy first of all
who tipped off the press about this
photograph I don't think they just
coincidentally discovered this
photograph a day after Ralph Northam
exposed the entire Democrats abortion
position which is to kill babies the
after they're born as they're being born
right before they're born he
posed what abortion for what it really
is which is infanticide the killing of
babies a day later his career is over
because of a photograph that someone
obviously had for a long time and they
were sitting on it
sitting on ammo just waiting to use it
so who tipped off the press according to
reports now it was a concerned citizen
not a political opponent and this is
from big league politics which published
this quote a concerned citizen not a
political opponent came to us and
pointed this at I I think there's a lot
there how it's being reported now is
that it was a medical school classmate
who was outraged by the infanticide
comments but how was the medical school
classmate outraged because he's pro-life
or because he's a Democrat I don't know
that the language you're a concerned
citizen not a political opponent makes
me think maybe this wasn't a political
opponent maybe this was a Democrat
maybe this tip came from a Democrat who
wanted to get abortion and post birth
abortion and infanticide out of the
headlines because it looks really really
bad for Democrats you know we talked
about this on the show last time on
Thursday for so long the left has had us
argue pro-life at the moment of
conception where the majority of
Americans support legal abortion three
days after conception two weeks after
conception whatever but the logical
conclusion of that is that the day of
birth or the day after birth or the day
before birth and now because of guys
like Ralph Northam and Andrew Cuomo and
other Democrats we're arguing about
abortion at its logical conclusion which
is the baby which is infanticide and
today other than on this show other than
on maybe a couple other conservative
leaning shows people aren't going to be
talking about Ralph Northam and
infanticide they're gonna be talking
about some stupid photo 35 years ago
that I truly care nothing about that is
truly not relevant to to our lives to
our public policy to racial relations to
abortion just remember this 3-4 days ago
this is what we were talking about from
Ralph Northam you know when we talk
about third trimester abortions these
are done
with the consent of obviously the the
mother with the consent of the
physicians more than one physician by
the way and it's done in cases where
there may be severe deformities there
may be a fetus that's non-viable so in
this particular example if a mother is
in labor I can tell you exactly what
would happen the infant would be
delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
so it really blown out of proportion
well something was blown out of
proportion here but it wasn't the
infanticide comments it's I guess it's
now been blown out of proportion because
of this new thing I'll say it here I'm
probably going to be called a racist for
saying this I think that it is worse to
slaughter babies after they've been born
than to wear blackface I know I'm gonna
be kicked off Twitter I'm gonna be
kicked off Facebook I'd say you're not
allowed to say that my show is gonna be
canceled
I think I think actually a lot of
reasonable people would agree it is
worse to kill infants after they've been
born in 2019 than it is to have worn
blackface in 1984 that's what I think
call me crazy call me crazy but of
course everybody thinks that and the
leek strategy worked we're now talking
about blackface which everybody can
condemn Democrats can go out and condemn
Democrat politicians presidential
candidates can go and condemn him call
for him to resign rather than talking
about infants who have been born alive
who are now being killed which Democrats
can't condemn the the Democrat
presidential candidates who have
announced and who haven't announced have
been very quiet about these abortion
bills in New York and possibly in Rhode
Island and in Virginia the ones that
allow you to kill a baby as it's being
born or I guess even after it's been
born they can't talk about that because
if they come out and say that's too far
then they then they create a losing
issue for Democrats they're going to
lose the primaries and the question
isn't obviously then going to be
if it's too late to kill a baby on the
day it's being born or the day after
it's been born what about the day before
it's been born what about the week
before it's been born what about it 26
weeks now you can kill a baby at 26
weeks in a whole lot of places women who
are 26 weeks pregnant have a giant belly
you can feel the baby kicking you can
see on 3-d sonograms that it's clearly a
baby what about that and it also it also
this strat at this league strategy which
was so good puts Republicans on the
defensive because we expressly we
experienced earlier books against them
this was the whole Brett Kavanaugh
incident was that Brett Kavanaugh wrote
about chugging beers in his high school
yearbook from the 80s and Republicans
rightly pointed out who cares what he
wrote in his high school yearbook who
cares what he did in the 80s I do I care
what's happening now so but just sort of
by principle Republicans don't want to
condemn people for things that happened
30 years ago especially if they've
changed especially if they've said that
they're sorry I don't care I don't care
if this guy wore blackface 35 years ago
I don't care if he wore the Ku Klux Klan
hood 35 years ago especially because
he's a Democrat governor and basically
all of them were the the Ku Klux Klan
hood for them for the majority of the
existence of the Ku Klux Klan what I
care about is is he sorry for it has he
changed is he doing things as governor
that are discriminatory toward people of
other races is he oppressing people is
if he's doing that I'm much more
concerned about that he's obviously
oppressing one class of people namely
babies or babies who are not wanted or
babies he says in that video he says
look we're not killing the good babies
we're killing those disabled babies
that's nobody wants a disabled baby no
who wants that no but nobody wants a
baby who has a mental or physical
deformity now come on that I care a lot
more about that so now Democrats by
switching up this story on Ralph Northam
there or trying trying at least to argue
on terms that they can win on these are
not comparable thing
and it's also worth pointing out as we
talked about this of these abortion laws
which are growing around the country now
when we talk about them we should make
clear that there are real differences
between arguing over these bills and
arguing over other Democrat policies
I always refrain or I am reluctant to
call things evil to call people evil to
condemn people categorically because
they want to raise taxes because even
because of awful political ideologies
like socialism I like to point out that
people who are fond of socialism usually
do so because they're ignorant because
maybe they have good intentions but the
road to hell is paved in good intentions
this is different these abortion bills
so-called abortion bills and really
infanticide bills are different they are
categorically evil they are
categorically barbaric they are evil
down to the core they're horrific they
transcend mere political difference and
we should talk about it that way it is
pure barbarism the people who support
that should not be permitted into polite
society people who vote to support that
to support the killing of babies after
they've been born should be ostracized
they should probably be deported at
least they should be held to criminal
stand there should be laws passed
against this sort of thing they should
be held to criminal standards it is
wickedness total evil depravity that's
what that guy did Ralph Northam that's
what he said on that radio show is we
should allow babies to be born and then
if they have a deformity or if their
parents don't like them then their
parents should be able to kill them
right on the table while they're smiling
up at their little mothers that's what
he said that is pure evil and the
Democrats have us not talking about that
they have us talking about a guy wearing
a racially insensitive costume 35 years
ago brilliantly done my hat goes off to
those cynical depraved political
strategists who managed to do that
was really really well done and pretty
horrific there is really really really
cynical and really effective now the
reason the reason that then Northam
comments are so dangerous for Democrats
is that they describe the reality of
abortion there's a new series coming out
from live action which shows this
beautifully it's really astounding when
you have arguments with people and you
have political debates with people you
never change their mind but this issue
as I say time and again is different I
was having a debate at politican with
Democrats like what's-his-name Bakari
sellers few others they said we need to
meet in the middle I said you can't meet
in the middle on abortion he said you're
right that's what you can't that's a
different kind of it this is a different
kind of issue we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to antinatalism we'll
get to the indian man who's suing his
parents for giving birth to him without
his consent we will get to the Holocaust
paradox how life may involve a lot of
suffering but suffering makes us
stronger we'll get to all of that
Providence and politics but first let's
think We the People holsters I love we
the people holsters they design
everything in-house they offer
custom-made holsters all produced in the
USA they designed them in-house which
means they don't use any third-party
molds for their holsters instead they
design every unique mold in Las Vegas to
order the best fit for each and every
firearm perfectly they constantly update
designs they add new designs every month
and that lets them stay up to date on
the newest models that come out We the
People holsters even have their own 3d
design team which measures every micro
millimeter of their guns to ensure the
perfect fit you can easily easily adjust
the can't and ride of your holster so
that it will fit comfortably and
securely at all times and you're able to
place the holster on your waistband and
change the angle they're just really
really high quality if you're going to
protect yourself if you're going to
exercise your Second Amendment rights
if you're going to put yourself in a
situation where you maybe you need to
defend your life maybe you need to
defend your family don't cheap out on
the holster that would be insane don't
get some generic mold that might not
work you get these wonderful custom
printed designs we the people holster
start at just 37 dollars a piece they
come with a lifetime guarantee they ship
free if it's not a perfect fit you can
send it back for a refund
go to We the People holsters calm /
Knowles KO wles We the People holsters
dot-com / Knowles enter promo code
Knowles KO w ali asset checkout get $10
off your first holster that is as low as
37 bucks and shipping is free with an
additional 10 bucks off using my promo
code that is a really good deal we the
people holsters dot-com / an old scanner
wles promo code Knowles Kenda WL he has
a check out for $10 off and then
tomorrow tune in for our latest episode
of backstage State of the Union the LA
wire god king jeremy boring ben shapiro
Andrew Klavan
Alicia crass and a little me will be
smoking stogies breaking down the issues
of the day separating the magma from the
non magma and enjoying those yum-yum
leftist leftist tears also with some
booze we will finally see Donald Trump
deliver the State of the Union address
hopefully maybe we won't I don't know
either way we're gonna have a lot of fun
tune in to find out as always only daily
wire subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to go subscribe
today at daily wire.com
10 bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me the Andrew
Fleming show the Ben Shapiro show the
Matt Walsh show ask questions on the
mailbag get it all of another Kingdom
you get the backstage you keep the
lights on you keep khofifah in my cup do
it if you're on Facebook or YouTube go
to daily wire calm you'll get the left
is tears tumblr you need the left tears
tumblr this is a great model
it holds those vintage in 1984 leftist
tears from the Virginia vineyards it's
really really good
where they're now stuck defending the
indefensible infanticide and on top of
that they're wearing KKK hoods again you
thought those days were over they're not
they're really not looking great right
now go to daily wire comm get your
left's to Sears tumblr we'll be right
back
the reason that Ralph Northam interview
there is so dangerous for Democrats
current Democrat politicians the
Democrats running for president is
because they describe the reality of
abortion the pro-abortion activists
always use jargon whenever people use
jargon and euphemisms you know that
they're hiding something from you
they'll say things when they describe
abortion in the in the pro-abortion
activists movement they'll say well we
use we use certain tools and employ
certain tools to find the cranium and
then we remove the product of pregnancy
from the uterus they all make it very
clinical there was that video of a woman
trying to describe abortion to children
because she's obviously deranged and she
said it just you know it's not a big
deal getting an abortion it's just like
in a weird body thing direct quote it's
kinda like going to the dentist you know
just a clinical but it's it's obviously
not like that so you hear all of the
clinical euphemisms jargon that the
pro-abortion crowd uses and then what is
Ralph Northam say because he's obviously
not a terribly intelligent man so when
he's out there talking on the radio he
says yeah the baby's born and then we
leave it on a table and then we kill it
if we want to he's the more honest
person he's the one telling you what it
is at least he's being honest all that
jargon is very dishonest so live action
pro-life organization as this new
serious video series where they go up to
people and say what do you think about
abortion and then the people say well I
support it mostly I think it's basically
fine and you know you should have the
right to choose and bla but whatever and
then they show them videos of what an
abortion is what it does the video isn't
obviously the videos are not being shown
in here because they're pretty graphic
and then instantly the people change
their mind this never happens in
political debate it happens over time
who maybe it's very hard to convince
someone except on this issue which is
different check it out
I think everyone should have a right to
it it's our body it's our decision right
so we want to go ahead with the
pregnancy or chabaud it it should be
solely on the person who's carrying the
baby so yeah that's what I feel about it
would you both support abortion all the
way up to the moment of birth oh yeah I
do
I do yes so now she's watching this
video you can see certain images from
the video on how it's being done
some graphics one word your thoughts on
what you saw yeah I mean until you see
something like that you don't know if
you think that you're gonna change your
opinion right I mean that's something I
would I would never want anyone to go
through right not myself not her or not
anyone I'm a mom to one right and I had
no idea this is how abortion takes place
right looking at that video and the way
it was performed yeah it's an eye-opener
so no I I don't think any kid any baby
any infant I mean um yeah any fetus
should go through that no listen she's
Stan she's so confused you can hear I
mean that's how you can really tell that
this is genuine she's saying I don't
think any infant I mean I mean fetus but
even if it's a I still don't think it
should go through that by the way fetus
means offspring it's a Latin word that
means offspring of a parent a really
effective tool and this is always the
tool I mean when you show the reality
when you show the images that is what is
going to convince people if you just
have a debate you know you kind of have
a bull session freshman year where
you're debating these abstract
ideological ideas of abortion and you
say well isn't isn't abortion sort of
like if a woman has changed to a
hospital bed and she's connected to a
parasite which she didn't ask to be
there and the pair is it morally licit -
okay well first of all these are thought
experiments are ridiculous they're not
terribly good analogies for it but
rather than use some silly thought
spearmint how about we just look at what
an abortion is they would they won't let
you do that
the left doesn't want you to do that
because when you look at the reality of
it when you see the story of what's
going on that's gonna make you pro-life
Oh for all but the most psychopathic
people that will make you pro-life it
has to the this is the difference
between an ideological manifesto and a
narrative this is why politics is
downstream of culture this is why the
culture matters so much is because we
live in stories ideological manifestos
doctrines boom boom boom five bullet
points that describe all of life they're
always wrong
that's why ideologies are always wrong
it's because they can't contain the
richness of life stories can get at the
richness of life this is why myths
describe life so much this is why
Christianity is the true myth it's the
greatest story ever told
the stories do and when we watch the
narrative of what an abortion is there's
no ambiguity I don't have to wonder
what's a cranium what's a what's this
tool look like how is what is a fetus or
an embryo or a blasto blastula or this
or that what is no it's a baby it's
obviously a baby and it's obviously
being killed and it's obviously trying
not to be killed and that's what it is
that's the story how you feel about
abortion really comes down to how you
feel about life that's what it's really
about it's not about what you think
about medical procedures it's not about
necessarily even abstract ideological
principles it's what do you think about
life is life ultimately good is life
ultimately a comedy is it significant
does it have purpose is your life geared
toward a purpose or is life a tale told
by an idiot full of sound and fury
signifying nothing at all which is it
those are the two views the traditional
view the Christian view the religious
view broadly is that life has a purpose
and as a Tilos the the classic ancient
view of the Aristotelian view there is a
purpose to life there is a significance
to life the modern and postmodern view
is that it's nothing it's an accident
we're just a bunch of weird
molecules bouncing together that we
accidentally ended up in this
semi-conscious probably not even free
state is probably all determined anyway
and then we delude ourselves with silly
illusions like love and virtue and
purpose but it's all just ridiculous and
it's really full of suffering and it's
really just awful it would be better not
to be born that there is an Indian guy
who is now embodying this in a really
farcical and dark way he is suing his
parents for giving birth to him without
his consent his name is Ralph
I'm sorry Rafael Samuel he says he has a
great relationship with his parents but
he's compared having children to
kidnapping and slavery he's leading a
movement called antinatalism and when I
first saw this I just assumed it was a
joke I assumed it was satire but the
weird thing about the age that we're
living in is that it's not clear you
have a sitting governor describing how
it's perfectly normal and good to kill
babies after they've been born if you
don't want them so in that world if this
is satire it's very good satire I'm not
convinced that it is this guy Rafael
says quote my life has been amazing but
I don't see why I should put another
life through the rigmarole of school and
finding a career especially when they
didn't ask to exist he's got this
campaign he's posting it on the Internet
where he says if parents truly know what
is good for their children why did they
have them isn't forcing a child into
this world and then forcing it to have a
career kidnapping and slavery the only
reason your children are facing problems
is because you had them which is true
that's why the children have problems is
because you gave them life so he's right
in that way but what it comes down to is
his life ultimately a good thing or
sight life ultimately a bad thing
there's a great little poem by Robert
Frost called a question and the question
is if the poem reads look me in the
Stars and tell me truly men of Earth if
all the soul and body scars were not too
much to pay for birth and what's funny
about that poem is it's not a question
it's actually an imperative right he's
actually telling you to do something and
of course
the person who is telling you this it
seems to be the voice of God the voice
of your Creator and you look up in the
stars I've had this experience I know
probably all of you have too and you
think gosh life has some suffering in it
but there is a transcendent beauty and
awesomeness to life to this world that
makes it all worthwhile it makes life is
good why it's the take away life is good
and the uh so there's that aspect of it
this the life is good view juxtaposed
with this postmodern Neela's view that
life is all suffering absurd meaningless
awful despair but then there's also the
idolatry of consent consent is the word
of the it's all we hear about is consent
it's the ultimate good we create an idol
of choice it is the ridiculous
conclusion of this idolatry of choice is
that you should be able to consent to
being born well you can't do that when
you're just a little glint in your
father's eye you know maybe you know
your your parents are getting a little
frisky nobody wants to think about
that's not a good image to have in your
head you're not able to consent to that
because you're born of the product of
that love and the Christian view of
course is that the whole the whole of
creation is a product of love the love
that moves the Sun and the other stars
this is what we see in especially
Dante's comedy spells this out very well
the love that moves to the world and the
other stores out of this love is all of
the creation this idolatry of consent
also undoes a ridiculous premise that
we've talked about a few times in the
last couple weeks which is this this
libertarian premise is hyper
individualist premise that you totally
own yourself and your body that you this
is all me it's all in my possession I am
sufficient I am an island unto myself
but you don't own that you are created
by God you are begotten of your parents
you have certain responsibilities not
just your parents not just to your
Creator to your community as well you
have bonds of loyalty and Duty we liked
because we're a selfish and decadent
culture we only like to talk about
rights
and then we invent a bunch of ridiculous
rights I have the right to your labor I
have the right to some new technological
advancement I've the right to pretend
that I'm of a different biological sex I
have the right to redefine social
institutions i blah blah blah all these
rights well really we should talk about
our duties we are born out of love I
mean obviously in a very literal sense
the love of our parents and the love of
our Creator for the creation that's what
we're born out of and this creates some
responsibilities that you should want to
embrace out of gratitude veneration
gratitude Providence you know what gives
away the game on this anti life crusade
that the left is going on is that they
come up with different excuses to reach
the same conclusion on this anti-natal
list
movement they also have a meme it says
quote should we continue to bring more
children in this world and accelerate
the process of environmental and social
degradation what wait a said what
argument are we I thought the argument
was we shouldn't bring children in the
world because it's unfair to them
because they didn't consent to it
because the world is awful and full of
suffering and terrible but now you're
saying we shouldn't bring children into
the world because it's bad for the awful
world which probably shouldn't exist in
the first place what you it seems as
though they have reached a conclusion
and it's a conclusion in search of a
premise the conclusion being life is bad
and then the various premises and
arguments even if they contradict one
another are used to buttress that
conclusion this is how a lot of
conspiracy theories fall apart
conspiracy theories often can sound
somewhat convincing and one reason they
sometimes fall apart is because you'll
have different conspiracy theories
disproving one event or arguing against
one event but all of the conspiracy
theories disagree with one another they
all contradict one another and the
conspiracists don't care because they've
reached a conclusion and they've got a
conclusion in search of a premise a
conclusion in search of an argument this
rhetoric is leading leading now to the
elimination of Down's syndrome people
all throughout the world in Iceland 100%
statistically 100 percent of people with
Down syndrome are killed Denmark it's 98
percent England it's 90 percent France
77 percent the you
67% to show that the let of the left
rather that this is wrong perhaps we
should start using leftist language Matt
Walsh had this brilliant phrase that he
used the other day referring to
undocumented infants
he said we should use the left language
don't talk about them as babies or
fetuses or this or that undocumented
infants trying to pass through the
border of the birth canal in search of a
better life this is what we should we
should talk about the Down syndrome
community how it's being targeted how
it's being persecuted how this is ablest
that's a leftist term that means
discrimination against people with
various disabilities and handicaps
actually in this case in the in the
slaughter of Down syndrome people that's
going on now even in our own country the
majority of Down syndrome people being
killed before they're born that's the
one time that these leftist terms can
apply these kind of vague leftist
slogans that such-and-such community
there's such-and-such victim group they
actually are a victim group they
actually are being they actually are
being wiped out that the left insists
that anyone who suffers should be killed
that's what they're saying that's what
the antinatalism is saying that's what
governor Northam is saying when he talks
about deformities and why we should kill
people with deformities what he's in
part there's a road to hell is paved in
good intentions there's a little sliver
of that here in a in a totally evil idea
which is that we should not allow people
to suffer and death would be better than
suffering the trouble is the logical
conclusion is that we all suffer so
therefore no one should be born there
was a study it just came out today in
Bloomberg the Holocaust paradox long
lives for those who survive the old idea
was that people who went through the
Holocaust and survived would have
shortened lives because they had all
this immense suffering you would hear
about this a lot and what they're now
finding is straight from Bloomberg quote
living through a horrendous event like
confinement in a concentration camp or
prisoner of war camp does create health
problems serious enough to shorten most
people's lives but those who survive
also seem to have other characteristics
perhaps a stronger immune system and a
more optimistic outlook than the general
population that tend to make people live
longer new research suggests that such
resilience can
often overcome scarring and this I mean
there is an analysis about this from the
American Medical Association we see this
again and again horace walpole has a
great line
the English Gothic writer he says life
is a comedy to those who think and a
tragedy to those who feel we hear this
again the light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it we
even hear it in this very popular slogan
which is whatever doesn't kill me makes
me stronger that we get these the
Inklings of the same thing
politics is downstream of culture
culture is downstream of religion and
the you know Edmund Burke founder of
modern conservative thought Russell Kirk
later explained that the conservative
vision is grounded in veneration and
Providence what one glaring example of
this Providence the divine order that
the world really does make sense that it
really does have purpose there really
does it is really as good Providence one
glaring example of this amid all this
crazy talk about infanticide actual
infanticide killing people after they've
been born came out this week every week
there were different readings at the
Catholic Mass these are not dependent on
the news cycle they're not decided by
the priest two hours beforehand they
have been set long long long in advance
and coincidentally or providentially
however you like it this is how the
entire mass reading began this week
quote the word of the Lord came to me
saying before I formed you in the womb I
knew you before you were born and I
dedicated you a prophet to the nation's
I appointed you
but do you gird your loins stand up and
tell them all that I command you be not
crushed on their account as though I
would leave you crushed before them for
it is I this day who have made you a
fortified City a pillar of iron a wall
of brass against the whole land against
Judas kings and princes against its
priests and people they will fight
against you but not prevail over you for
I am with you to deliver you says the
Lord amid all talk of infanticide amid
all talk of Ceph suffering is why we
shouldn't live at all why life is
ultimately bad
Providence is a great comfort and
comfort means just strengthened we think
of comfort as little dolly safe spaces
hugging kumbaya that's not what it means
it means to strengthen you can comfort
people with tough love - it means to
strengthen them with come 40s strength
even when things look bleak asst one
cannot deny the comforting signs of
Providence pervading this life which is
a gift and a very good thing we'll end
on that note and we'll skip the
Superbowl cuz everybody else did -
lowest ratings in ten years too bad for
them that's our show
come back tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael gnosis is the Michael and old
show see you soon
[Music]
the michael dole's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19